guys it was kind of slow motion to see
the clouds coming off the mountains
yesterday over the valley i was really
hoping we'd get some rain out of them
but it just never happened beautiful
skies today nice and sunny out there not
much in the way of wind although i think
the afternoon will be on the breezy side
we've got a lot of upper 70s some low
80s in the middle of town aliante at 80
degrees the strip at 81 green valley at
83. it's been a little breezy out at red
rock temps in the upper 60s out there
mid 60s now for indian springs perump at
70 mid 70s for sandy valley and boulder
city as well as mesquite right now 76 86
for laughlin 72 for kingman and 57 for
cedar city pretty much any direction you
drive this morning you're going to be
fine but there have been some
thunderstorms over in flagstaff down to
phoenix and up into central utah so
along i-15 today you could run into some
of those thunderstorms east of clark
county we're not looking for
thunderstorms today looking for sunshine
and heat 103
sunset by the way at 802. our normal
high is 102 now
for our first weekend of summer so we're
going to be a little bit above that the
low pressure that opened up through
california and northern nevada has
already slipped into northern utah so
that's going to keep things popping for
thunderstorms utah all the way down
through arizona the monsoon moisture is
still down here and you can see
thunderstorms very active north of
phoenix with a lot of lightning we had a
couple of cells that were sliding by us
yesterday up around amargosa valley and
then some that got real close to the
moapa valley up through northwest
arizona but we just couldn't get
anything as far as rain for us in the
valley so today we're back to breezy and
hot
in the valley but up at mount charleston
78 very comfortable please wear the life
jackets out at lake mead today it is
going to be very hot at 104 and those
winds will be switching around a little
bit 20 25 miles an hour we're looking at
103 for the valley again so slightly
above normal that uv index of 11. that
will last through the weekend and boy
we're just going to have a long string
of hot sunny days 105 through the
weekend still breezy on saturday even at
106 a couple of days in the eight day
forecast july begins a week from today